être enregistrés on l'entend souvent
celle là sachez que selon la loi vous
avez le droit d'obtenir une copie de cet
enregistrement parce que votre voix est
considérée comme renseignements
personnels sauf que dans les faits des
entreprises sont souvent réticentes à ce
genre de demande ce qui peut vous faire
travailler fort sans compter que
certaines effacent leurs enregistrements
après un certain temps par exemple chez
bell ont fait le ménage après treize
mois chez vidéotron ces trois ans mais
dites-vous que six entreprises a le
droit de vous enregistrer vous aussi
vous en avez le droit ce qui est délicat
c'est de rendre public cet
enregistrement sans raison valable par
contre pour faire valoir vos arguments à
l'entreprise ou en cours pas de problème
considérant que la plainte numéro un sur
les fournisseurs de télécoms porte sur
les divergences entre l'oral et l'écrit
c'est bon à savoir on dit toujours qu'on
n'est jamais si bien servi que par soi
même alors munissez vous d'un appareil
ou d'une appli pour vous enregistrer
parce que
et pour vous aussi partiellement
[Musique]